welcome to this video playing saw you
like Joey name let's see what happens
italian game with the quick Queenie to
Queenie to is not very very common
probably because of a cookie file let's
let's do that huh
I'm interesting very uncommon way to
play well maybe I can go here just just
play play simple moose okay
maybe play it play it simple just just
take an age six young the other opinion
is a slide slide annoyance of course hmm
kmetz kawaii 5 this might be a useful
tempo and then need to get rid of firm
and the pin probably nuts let's do that
intending night age five
I can probably still play night age 5
which wouldn't surprise me if it was
possible yeah come on this should be
technically possible 95 that's just 93
okay so he allows me to take down one I
def form a I'm not sure that neither for
is a great idea so here and let's see
it's nice g4 here possibility yeah a
four is unprotected if he takes Bishop
takes as the temple on the rook
I mean he played everything very quickly
but not sure that this is also great
another Bishop b5 with check a case well
an a6 proves to be a useful move okay I
can flick in this check to make sure you
cannot cancel but this is probably not
happening anyway still maybe the chick I
can take you also check your occlusion
Queen to e7 this is the main thing is
not so much about castling right
no 27 yeah he has some the H file open
so maybe he can use the look with they
are something like that um he will
probably play five him yeah I can start
with this
Jim I've got two bishops against two
nights that's not not bad okay maybe
here does not seem to be any other
square of one minute down on the clock
that sir that's might prove to be
problematic the position is of course
quite nice I can also take with the
Queen ER i prefer that keeping the rook
on the D file
yeah keeps the gets the rook back into
play but also exposes a five if I've is
a weakness now that can be a may be used
in some end games especially with
further trades happening
that's not not bad on c6 this Bishop on
the long diagonal maybe I want be sick
b6 could be useful so that night a5 is
never going to happen but ok it's not
not really a threat Knight a5 not really
so what is my my plan here probably
queen dee 521 get the Queen's off yeah
you cannot even take this G to hang
so the rook must move to g4 it's very
ugly mmm i can i can give the check then
on the one but i'm not sure if it's the
optimum i can also just cover this on g5
like Bishop e7 but then it's got
lucrative for Jack and one this is this
is good any way of winning a poem that
is not really not really the point the
hordes of the whole the whole position
is good oops oh sorry I wanted to go to
to be too and I completely forgot that
this is impossible oh not good that's
not so good ok so b5
yeah maybe I should have gone to a one
else so that rook a to s is easily
playable yeah yeah I don't know what is
he doing with the night u6 I take with
the pawn and now I'm threatening to trim
the night thats its weird why am i
overlooking stuff which is of course
always possible looks like self trap of
this night time morning he needed to
just go to e3 then ok it's it's
comfortable for me but yeah I can go
here this was the second threat white
resides yeah it's it's nice anyway are
with the two bishops of course but he
can still put up resistance when he if
he puts it to e3 on a 3 cannot play
whoopsie to know I mean I can't go here
for example and just and just continue
that's just nice the two bishops are of
course dominating the night it's quite
quite substantial yeah the problem was
that already here I have two bishops
against some nights and if there is
nothing particularly bad happening this
is good enough to tour to have a big
advantage and I still with the good
defense it should be possible to to put
up resistance but yeah I also get the
fantastic ji diagonal diagonal now our
Bishop e7 is strong yeah this is strong
I didn't see that because g4 Hanks this
I played a bit a bit too quickly it
takes takes and here you can can even
think about
I'm keeping the Queen's on this this
seems good here okay I didn't see this
move computer move Queen Queen h1 this
is completely winning ok ok ok but ok
the endgame was I was a safe choice here
it's not not much fun ok one was a bit
stronger but it keeps an advantage and
he fell apart quite quickly ok thanks
for watching